this verdict justin this has been a
long-running
investigation this has culminated uh in
the conviction for manslaughter of a
serving uh west mercier police officer
pc benjamin monk he was one of the first
to
respond to calls of shouting in a street
in telford this was back in
august 2016 and the man that he
confronted when he got to that scene
was the former professional footballer
dalian atkinson of course best known for
his time at
aston villa there was a confrontation
that happened
in the street in the early hours of the
morning pc monk used his taser he
tasered
dalian atkinson for some 33 seconds the
normal cycle of a taser
is five seconds and this trial has heard
how pc monk
then kicked dalian atkinson at least
twice
in the head now pc monk always maintains
that he was terrified
of the 48 year old during this
confrontation
by the time paramedics arrived at the
scene dalian atkinson had
lost consciousness and he died a short
time later in hospital and much of the
medical evidence focused on the fact
that dalian atkinson was in very poor
health at the time
he was in end stage renal failure but
the jury uh have looked at all the
evidence
and concluded that pc monk should be
convicted
of the manslaughter of the former
professional footballer
dalian atkinson the jury now still
deliberating a verdict in the case
of a second officer mary ellen bentley
smith
she uh stands trial for assault
of dalian atkinson and the jury still
deliberating
uh on that but returning their guilty
verdict in the case of pc benjamin monk
clearing him of murder but finding him
guilty of manslaughter
so we just await now the jury's decision
in the case of his colleague at the time